next question  easy which is say Kanye West yang as the  unity ticket for 2020 or 2024 question  mark I sure don't think so  which is not to say that West is not  motivated by similar things that  motivate us in fact I'm sure he is I  think he is a patriot he is courageous  and he's concerned and so he announced  his run for the presidency now my guess  would be that he's going to quickly  discover why his run for the presidency  is very unlikely to work and why it  could well play into the scenario that  we have in front of us badly and so I do  hope he will make contact with us  because to the extent that he is trying  to solve a problem for the nation which  I believe he is trying to solve the best  way to do that is to come talk to people  who have been thinking about this  structurally and figure out if we can't  align you know that would be ideal  so anyway Kanye if you're out there we  are absolutely open to talking and  respect  [Music]